live okay sure you know live
yeah yeah thank you tom well i'd like to
uh welcome you all to this virtual
meeting of the plans committee
um i'll just go through some basic rules
for this meeting
the committee probably fed up in me
reading these out but for those who
watch on youtube i think it's
it's important that i do at the start of
the meeting we will mute
all microphones except nine please leave
all microphones muted
unless you're asked by me to speak
residents who want to exercise their
right to speak at the meeting
have been asked to register in advance
and also have had
the option of sending in a statement to
us which will be read out
by the planning manager or if they've
been sent a link
to temporarily join the meeting to speak
in person
we've got three people registered to
speak today
to indicate to me that you would like to
speak or propose a second emotion
please press the raise the hand symbol
in the participants menu
on your screen these are shown on my
screen
in the order that they are pressed and
i'll deal with them in order
giving the appropriate officer or
counsellor
the opportunity to answer in between
where necessary
i'll also return to the counsellor to
check that they are happy
with the responsive received
to ensure clarity and accuracy during
virtual meetings
all votes will be cast via a verbal
recorded vote
and names will be read out in
alphabetical order by the clerk
please state your vote clearly and
slowly when your name is read out
unmuting and muting your microphone is
necessary
please remember that to ensure full
transparency
as i said a minute ago with the
democratic process
this meeting is being live streamed on
the council's youtube channel
i ask you all to be patient during this
meeting and to understand that
processes and advice may take a little
longer than usual
and we do now and again have one or two
glitches with a technical
presentation i'll now ask each
member of the committee to introduce
themselves
and then the officers present so sandra
if you'd just like to name
the councils and let them introduce
themselves
yes thank you chair cancel a bowtie
good morning richard fountain i
represent heartland ward
councillor brown good morning
i represent uh great torrington and i am
margaret brown thank you councillor
christie
ah thank you uh yes my name is peter
christie uh i represent biddeford north
thank you
councillor craigie good morning
uh my name's ruth cravey and i represent
biddeford east cancer leather
good morning everybody i'm chris leather
and i represent northern ward
councillor lock good morning i'm uh
rosemary knock and i represent
two rivers and three wars ward
cancelling my golf
good morning my name is dermott goff and
i represent biddeford north
councillor watson morning i'm pete
watson and
i represent broadies and councillor
wiseman
yeah you're muted counselor wiseman
i've done it i've done it now richard
wiseman i represent the
chevy langtry ward thank you chair
thank you and if the officers present
would like to introduce themselves now
please starting with sean
good morning members good morning
members of public my name is sean
harrington and i'm the planning manager
at torres district council
hello i'm stacey dorey and i'm the head
of legal and governance at torridge
district council
good morning i'm laura davis i'm
principal planner
and i'm michael newcombe representing
the highway authority standing in for
matt collins who made the original
recommendation from highways
that's everybody that's everybody
present and thank you
yeah um right item one on the agenda is
apologies for absence
there are no apologies for absence
because we've got a full compliment on
the committee
thank you for that item two on the
agenda
is the minutes of the previous plans
committee meeting
held on the 3rd of december on pages
4-12
and i shall move those from the chair if
somebody would like to second them
i'll second that to you thank you
councillor watson
sandra will go to the vote on the
acceptance of those minutes i've
proposed some
councillor watson seconded them thank
you chair
councillor belton at four councillor
brown
four councillor christy or
councillor craigie or penciller leather
or chancellor lock or
councillor mcgoff or ansel watson
or and councillor wiseman or
unanimous chair thank you sandra
item three on the agenda is declarations
of interest
members with interest to declare should
refer to the agenda item and describe
the nature of their interest when the
items being considered
elected members of devon county council
and town
parish count or parish councils who've
considered
a planning application by virtue of
their membership of that council
hold a personal interest and are deemed
to have considered the application
separately and the expressed views of
that council
do not bind the members concerned who
consider the application afresh
because as i said we all this is a
meeting that we have all the latest
information on the applications which
isn't necessarily sort town and parish
council meetings
item four on the agenda is to agree
the agendas between parts one and two
there is no part two
five is urgent matters information to be
brought forward
with the permission of the chair well
i've nothing to bring forward
only the fact that we probably will be
having
an extra planning meeting in february
nobody else has got anything to
contribute so we'll move on then to
item six which is public participation
and i'll advise the committee that
we've got three requests to speak with
only the one application this morning
to consider and we've got chris bond
speaking in support he sent a statement
in which sean
harrington our planning manager will
read out we've got
susan lander to speak against a member
of the public
and councillor dart is award member to
speak
um after the presentation of the
application
the order of the speakers is as follow
the planning officer gives their
presentation and then
an eternal parish council representative
who wishes
to speak for or against the application
they have three minutes
and up to two public speakers who wish
to speak against the application
they've got three minutes each as well
and up to
two public speakers in support of the
application
they also have three minutes to present
their
view and then tori's ward member
there's no time limit on their
contribution they speak last
right okay planning applications agenda
item seven
yeah councillor belton's raised his hand
yeah yeah it was just saying mr chairman
although i called this application in
um i come with a clear and open mind
okay thank you councillor bolton
right planning applications then
the information recommendations and
advice contained in the reports
are correct as at the date of
preparation which is more than 10 days
in advance as a committee meeting
due to these time constraints any
changes
or necessary updates to the reports will
be provided in writing or orally
at the committee meeting on
7a is the application to consider this
morning
on pages 13 to 32 and i'll hand over to
laura
davis who will present this application
thanks laura
thank you chair so the application is
for the erection of four bungalows
with a new access and associated works
on land
off of elizabeth lee close and north
road in bradworthy
we just got a couple of updates to
advise members of first
first we've had an email from the
applicants um which is responding to
comments made by the parish council
in relation to the planning need for the
development
the option of a business use on the
sites the unsustainable nature of the
development and
avoidance of planning contributions when
considered in relation to adjacent
approvals and concerns about
traffic volume using elizabeth lee close
many of these points have already been
addressed within the officers report
but just to note that the recommendation
you have in front of yourselves this
morning um
includes a contribution towards
education infrastructure
and at the primary school in bradworthy
and also and
towards secondary school transportation
to holdsworthy community college for the
pupils generated by the development
um and they'll be secured via section
106 as is set out in the recommendation
and just to advise members that
contributions towards education and the
provision of on-site affordable housing
were included within one of the
previous permissions which the applicant
was also responsible for on the adjacent
site to the west
i'm also just an amendment to condition
nine
further two sort of discussions with the
applicant
um it's outlined on page 31 of your
agenda
um and it's recommended that the wording
of condition line to be amended
so that we seek the provision of the
link road through from elizabeth lee
close and at least
two of the associated dwellings approved
on the previous permission
to be completed prior to the
commencement of the development in front
of you this morning
so the amended wording is is there for
you
uh the reason for the condition would
remain unaltered
so to move on to the plans we've got the
application site plan that members may
recall from the site visits
so the application site outlined in red
there
the large blue lined area to the east
is also in the ownership of the
applicants and the two
outlined blue areas to the west also
within the applicant's ownership
and these areas to the west are formed
part
of the allocation within the local plan
for
policy brd01 for residential development
and the majority have
previously received planning permission
for residential developments
um just to remind members we've got
residential properties to elizabeth lee
close to the west
you have a bowling green and the
associated pavilion to the south of the
site
and an industrial estate just sort of
the southeast corner
so just to remind members where the
policy allocation
falls the application site is set
outside of the settlement boundary so it
is immediately
to the eastern side of the brdo one
allocation that's outlined in pink there
for you
um and then aerial photos showing
context
currently the application site is an
open agricultural field
um with surrounding agricultural fields
to all sides apart from the south
and as i say the planning permission has
previously been granted for
uh residential development to the west
side
that's not being commenced on site thus
far
and just to give a zoomed in uh view
and the hedgerows at the moment to the
north to the west and to the southern
boundaries uh the eastern boundary to
the site is actually
unmarked on site so to go through a few
of the photographs of the site so this
is looking across the southern portion
of the site
back to properties on elizabeth lee
place
and then views to properties on landon
road langdon road sorry
and the bowling green pavilion that's
just
visible there by the telegraph pole
a view alongside the proposed access
road would run pretty much along the
hedge row
that's in front of you there
a view along the proposed access from
elizabeth lee close so the proposed
access would run along the left-hand
side of the photograph
there
view across the site looking from
the western boundary towards the eastern
boundary and down towards the main road
and which runs into bradworthy
and the as i say the eastern boundary of
the site is not marked
physically on site currently
and then a view across the site towards
its northern boundary
and towards the south again towards
properties on on langdon road and the
bowling green pavilion that's just
visible there
this is a view i'm from the bowl across
the bowling green and the associated
pavilion i'm on langdon road
and so the site is currently obscured
to a certain degree by the existing
hedgerows which would be retained
and to refresh members memories about uh
the access from elizabeth
close so there's an existing cul-de-sac
which has already been extended by
previous permissions
so the existing and the approved
consents
would run directly in front of your
sales there
and then the proposed development would
be beyond those using this access route
and then just for context i know some
concerns about the uh the access
arrangements this is the view along
north road looking
down towards the center of bradworthy
showing the
junction with elizabeth lee close on the
left hand side there
and then the reverse view so looking out
of bradworthy
with the junction with elizabeth lee
close on the right hand side
just run through the plans this is the
proposed site layout so we've got four
bungalows running in a north-south
arrangement across the site
and the hedgerows would be retained to
the north
to the west and to the southern
boundaries of the site
and the access road would continue
through from the previously permitted
development
which is shown in with the red dotted
lines
you can see on the plan there
the proposal is before bungalows and so
we've proposed
elevations and floor plans for plot one
with three bedroom bungalow being
proposed in traditional design
and then the proposed floor plans and
elevations for plots two
three and four again three-bedroom
bungalow
this sets out the proposed landscaping
so
confirms the retention of the hedgerows
in the majority
of the sites and there will be the
removal of the hedgerow which if you
look along the access road you can see
outlined in red
and to allow the access road to continue
through from the previously approved
development
i'll draw members attention also to the
proposal for
adding hedge bank into the southern
boundary of plot
two which you can just see sort of the
lighter green there to the north of the
access road
and proposals put timber fencing in
between each of the rear gardens
and then the proposal for a 1.2 meter
high
timber post and rail fence along the
eastern
boundary to section off the site from
the remainder of the field
so the applicant has also proposed
details of how the hedge bank would be
formed
with a meter high with planting on top
and details of that planting
the proposal includes an attenuation
pond to be created to the east of the
application site
online which is also within the
applicant's ownership
the details of the attenuation base and
confirms that they will have sufficient
volume
to accommodate surface water runoff from
the proposed scheme as well as the
previously approved
development um and this will accommodate
a one in 100 year
event with 40 for climate change
so the material considerations in this
case um
firstly the principle of development as
set out in the office's report the
application site is located outside of
the settlement boundary of bradworthy
and therefore it would not be supported
in principle by policy
st07 notwithstanding this we need to be
mindful of the council's lack of
five-year housing land supply
as a material consideration along with
the provisions
of policy st 21 and this is set out
in some detail on pages 19 20 and 21 of
the officers report
secondly the impact on landscape
character and appearance the proposal
would be for four single story dwellings
with the retention majority of hedge
banks to provide sunscreen in the
development in the wider landscape
the traditional design of the dwellings
is considered to be suitable in this
location
and the development is likely to be
viewed in the context of surrounding
residential development
to the west as approved and also
existing development to the south as
part of the edge of the settlement of
bradworthy
in the wider landscape um so officers of
the opinion that
the application would be in keeping with
the provisions of policies
dmo4 and dmo8a of the local plan
in terms of the landscape impact i'd
also draw your attention again to
condition nine
seeking to ensure that the access road
and a proportion of the approved
development
on the adjacent site is also constructed
prior to the proposed development
commencing
thirdly impact on residential amenities
the proposed development is not
considered to result in a harmful impact
on the amenities of existing occupiers
or future occupants
a condition is included within the
recommendation condition
six to ensure that two because the
proposed trees
to the rear of plot three are planted in
advance the occupation of that plot just
to make sure that there is
a reasonable level of amenity for future
occupants and on that basis
the development's considered to be in
keeping with policy dmo1
in terms of access and parking
each of the proposed dwellings would
include off street parking with
driveways and garages
the proposed access is via elizabeth lee
close
this transport statement has been
provided by the applicants
this has been reviewed by the county
council's highways officers raise no
objection
and the highways officer is here with us
today to assist any
in any queries if you have in that
regard i'd also draw members attention
to the
proximity of the site to various
facilities and services within
bradworthy
and number five in terms of drainage the
foul drainage would be connected to the
mains
and as previously mentioned the surface
water drainage has now been amended to
include an attenuation pond which would
discharge
at an attenuated rate and southwest
water raised no objections to
either of these drainage arrangements
number six is the ecology uh the
applicant has
supported the application with an
ecological impact assessment which
doesn't identify any likely impacts on
protected species or their habitats
a number of recommendations are included
relating to proposed relocation hedge
bank and enhancements
and these can be secured via conditions
and we've got condition seven
to ensure that the development is
undertaken in accordance with
with the ecological impact assessment
recommendations
uh section seven section 106
um the county council's education
officer has commented on the proposal
and the likely people numbers to be
generated
as a result a contribution towards
primary school infrastructure at bravo
the primary has been
requested along with a contribution
towards secondary school transport
holdsworthy community college
and those would be secured via a section
106 agreement as part of the
recommendation in front of you today
and finally number eight the planning
balance
just to confirm there are actually two
typographical errors in the planning
balance section on page 26
in the second to last paragraph
this should reflect that the application
is actually made in full
not in outline as indicated there
apologies
and therefore officers consider that
significant weight can be attributed to
the likely
deliverability of the site in a timely
manner
and in addition within the same
paragraph it also indicates that nine
dwellings have been approved on the
adjacent site and this should actually
reflect 12.
so in terms of the planning balance in
accordance with the recommendation the
requirements of the mppf
it's considered it's necessary to
consider whether the adverse impacts of
the development
would significantly and demonstrably
outweigh the benefits
the officer's report considers that the
benefits of the site
including it being well related to the
existing settlement in close proximity
to services and facilities in the local
centre
and in keeping with the predominantly
residential character of the surrounding
area
would weigh in its favor in addition
the application is made in full and the
site is within the applicant's ownership
to increase the likelihood of the
development being able to be delivered
it's considered the adverse impacts of
the proposed development being outside
of the settlement boundary
would not significantly and demonstrably
outweigh the benefits
when assessed against the policies in
the local plan and the mppf as a whole
so on this basis the recommendations for
approval subject to the section 106
agreement
and the conditions outlined thank you
chair thank you laura that was a very
comprehensive presentation of the
application thanks for that well the
first
speaker was chris bond who sent in a
statement which
sean harrington our planning manager
will please read out
uh thank you chair so this is a
statement
from christopher bond dear committee
members
please consider the following concerning
the three points raised by councillor
belton
for the calling in respect to planning
application 1-0858
2020 ful
one the application site immediately
joins the land identified within the
adopted north evan and torres local plan
brd01 the planning spectra
has confirmed the overall location is in
a sustainably accessible position
within one zero seven seven one slash
207
out the location being within a short
level walk of the village square
compares favorably with other recent
planning applications including
one slash zero four one six twenty
twenty seven
witcott house bucks cross and one
zero five one two twenty twenty slash
out
land off station road howell junction
the council accepts that it cannot
demonstrate a five year supply of
housing land
where such a situation occurs due to a
shortfall in housing delivery
local plan policy st 21 2 provides
principal support for residential
development outside the defined
settlement limits
the planning spectra has also confirmed
the presumption in favor of sustainable
development
set out in paragraph 11d of the
framework otherwise known as the tilted
balance
the tilted balance requires that
permission should be granted
unless any adverse impact of doing so
would significantly and demonstrably
outweigh the benefits
when assessed against framework policies
taken as a whole
in terms of the benefits of the proposal
there would be a short-term economic
benefit from the construction phase of
the development
and longer term benefits from the future
residents continued reliance on local
facilities and services
in addition the education contribution
amounts to eighteen thousand and eighty
five pounds
the four dwellings will represent a
valuable contribution to the housing
shortfall
there are also social benefits by
providing bungalows in an accessible
location
the parish council recognized the need
for bungalows within the local community
on the basis there is potential to free
up houses for younger families as
indicated in
one zero three one nine so that's 2020
oet lander joining my house bradworthy
two the suggestion that this is a
piecemeal development to avoid
contributions is incorrect
and the application made has been
strictly governed by tdc's planning
policies
at the relevant time they were submitted
the previous planning application
contained a section 106 agreement
to provide two affordable houses
together with other cash obligations
amounting to 37
37 583 pounds
three the draft neighbor plan and brd-01
have always anticipated access of
elizabeth leah close
detailed plans have been approved by tdc
for this access
a detailed transport statement has been
submitted to clarify the situation with
regard to any additional car movements
due to this application the existing
properties within elizabeth lee up close
have two off-road parking spaces
per dwelling the parish council did not
raise any concerns about traffic issues
at the time of 1-105.9 that's 2019-4
for 7 units thank you christopher bond
frics thank you chair thank you sean
uh the first speaker against it
is susan lander i see you're with us
this morning so you've got three minutes
susan to present your
objections to the application thank you
chair
uh good morning uh bradley parish
council strongly believes that
applications for housing either single
or multiples
should not be allowed throughout the
district just because the appeal at
burwood lane was lost by tdc in march
2020
the parish council has made this point
in their response to applications
and now feels that their comments are
being ignored and many other parish
councils feel the same
all because of the perceived lack of a
five-year housing land supply
the officer mentions the burwood appeal
three times in the committee report
and the lack of a five-year housing land
supply also three times
we believe that this shows the reliance
on both the appeal and the perceived
deficits of deliverable housing for
torridge
by the planning officers the parish
council maintains that there is also a
strong need for employment opportunities
within bradbury
although not recorded as a rural
strategic policy site
within the made local plan the area to
the north of the existing industrial
estate
is recognized as the best and most
appropriate area
for future industrial development the
council feels that to continue the
expansion
of additional housing into the area it
could stop any future business
used because of the proximity of these
four bungalows to the potential area of
industrial expansion
whilst the parish council recognizes the
need for single-story accommodation
it also believes it could result in
environmental complaints about
noise and pollution rabady has at
present
an approximate total of 74 houses in
permitted planning applications
that have not been proceeded with
another three applications are still in
planning
adding 15 extra dwellings two of these
applications are from this applicant
or his family the parish council are
surprised to know that the planning
officer states
that because there have been no planning
applications to date from the second
site
at mill road with an allocation of 15
units
that the site may be undeliverable
within the time frames of the local plan
the parish council thinks this is a
speculative statement
and that has no credence nor is it the
case that because the 12 units already
with planning approval from site 1
are under the same ownership as these
bungalows that this indeed makes them
more likely to be delivered
again this is a speculative statement
and not a valid balanced planning reason
to allow this application
we maintain there is no housing
necessity in bradley to allow this
creeping beyond this site area
there is still deliverable housing space
in that identified area
all growth needs to be sustainable for
future generations
so where there is housing there also
needs to be a growth of transport
education health services recreation and
employment
and as in this case housing should not
impede the growth of the more important
employment
can i ask you to wind up now please
thank you the parish council would also
add that their neighborhood plan was
abandoned after four years of hard work
because of the continued growth of
housing
in the parish despite the work on the
plan and authority's own policy
on housing thank you thank you thanks
for your contribution
and then our next speaker now is ward
member councillor anna dart
and counselor dart you've
no time limit on your contribution
thank you chair thank you committee um i
said i would speak today
really to bolster the valid points made
by sue at bradley parish council
the village has been subjected to a
considerable
amount of opportunistic piece meal
development
outside of the boundary and
over recent years this is
coupled with the lack of proven
five-year housing land supply
ultimately cost them their neighborhood
plan and largely
any control over development four years
worth of hard work
time and resource was put into that
neighborhood plan
with so much community involvement
consultation and ultimately it didn't
come to fruition
largely due to the despondency and
frustration
by the people driving it forward as time
after time
they were overruled with more and more
exception sites
such as this that were granted
permission because of the five-year lack
of five-year housing
in spite of this the parish council
learnt a lot
about the expectations and the needs of
the village and the community as a whole
and as such sue raises really valid
points
you know you cannot have constant
residential development
without enabling the village to grow in
other ways as well
and be sustainable and strategic
planning
is necessary this is basically just
opportunistic planning um bradley's got
so much to offer as a rural
settlement as i've said before in
previous plans um
it's got great grounding and huge
potential for sustainable
strategic growth in all areas
but time and time again we are seeing
the logical way and approach forward to
planning
being overruled by these
well really yeah opportunists
it's unfortunate we're in the situation
we're in but there we are
the other um thing i wanted to mention
was that
the access to this site i still feel
should be scrutinized by the committee
because it does go through
um a long-standing residential
development where there are children so
i think that's worthy of due
consideration thank you
thank you councillor dart with no other
speakers
um to this application so i'll throw it
up now to the committee
who'd like to start the discussion on
this
no hands up to start but yo counselor
wiseman
thank you chair i'll kick off then if uh
if that's all right
um i just wondered if i could ask a
couple just a simple question of the
plan of the highways officer is
i'm not sure is elizabeth lee close
adopted at the moment
my understanding is adopted yes right
that's just interesting um now i
referred back to
um the initial consultation from
highways now i know on their second uh
consultation submission they said that
they had no
no um no reasons for the permission to
be refused
no but not all the previous questions
were answered
they obviously flagged up that they were
quite concerned with the um
safety issues due to lack of safe route
for pedestrians well that hasn't been
addressed has it
how you know what we're going to do
about that well would it be okay if i
give my general thoughts which hopefully
will answer a few questions
uh sort of chair i'm asking you
questions what's happening yeah and
um and like i said if there's any
subsequent questions from that then um
please jump in would that be okay yeah
that's all right michael so michael
newcomb
thanks councillor wiseman
um so address some of those issues
thanks michael
yeah sure so just to clarify um the
original decision was made by matt
collins he's not able to make it today
so i'm standing in and
i've reviewed his um thoughts on both
recommendations he sent
in and i visited the site as well i can
confirm
so just again if i just briefly give a
few my thoughts and i said if if i
haven't answered anything please please
let me know
access onto north road provides
excellent visibility in both directions
and easily um has the 43 meters in
either direction that we'd expect
one elizabeth lee close at the moment
it's effectively a shared surf uh shared
space arrangement
um such an arrangement is generally
supported by manufacturers
there are a number of conditions they
normally look for such as
low speed low speed environments and low
traffic flows
and what manual for streets looks at for
low traffic flows is under
100 vehicle movements an hour
i would add on top of that the walking
on the highway is a normal part of devon
life
and examples can be found in many of
devon's towns and villages
as long as the conditions are suitable
and i've mentioned some of those this is
considered safe and suitable
on top of that i'm also not aware of any
persistent
consistent collision issue associated
with um with sheds
which air surfaces with regards to
elizabeth lee close
it is a slow speed environment already
there are low traffic flows
and i think that on the transport i
believe on the transport statement
um i'm going to quote from matt now this
suggests that the additional level of
traffic generated by the
total of 40 new dwellings will be 69
movements per day
on top of a predicted existing figure of
49
uh trips per day of the existing 10
dwellings
um and effectively the proposed
development looks to extend this albeit
it has
footpaths within it and and to summarize
i am struggling to join a conclusion
other than
um that the proposed development office
saving suitable access
all right thanks for that michael
who counselor christie
yeah thank you um couple of points um
what intrigued me was the parish
council's statement
um but i i was slightly confused
when sean read out the letter from the
applicant he said that so the applicant
was doing these piecemeal developments
because
it was in line with torridge's planning
policies
can he explain that because i don't know
of any policies that said that
um i have got another couple of
questions but if sean could just answer
that
uh thank you council christie um clearly
that was the statement from christopher
bond as opposed to my statement
um so i i'm not sure if i can answer on
behalf of christopher it's appropriate
for me to do so
um from our view
i assume what the applicant is stating
is that at the time
the applications were determined in
accordance with the policies
the planning policies at that time uh
including the requirement for
uh obligations financial contributions
and affordable housing
but like i say that is the statement of
christopher bond as opposed to you
officers
thank you i still don't quite understand
them anyway um
could i ask about the um the statement
by the parish council
because it talks about recreation and
doctor's surgery as well
now we've got this one in at the moment
from in biddeford where they're applying
for money for the doctor's surgery
and would there be any recreational
payments for this because the parish
council as
council of data says spent a long time
on their
their plan and they do they seem to be
very aware of these things
is there any uh truth in what the parish
council said here about
avoiding all these payments
can i perhaps um and comment on that
chair yes laura
um i i know that we have had requests
from the nhs towards um primary
healthcare infrastructure in bradworthy
on larger developments recently but
um i can assume that the scale of this
development
doesn't meet the threshold for
requesting additional uh contributions
in this instance
thank you laura and uh can i just take
out one more point um on page 27 and
this i think was um
brought up uh by the public speaker as
well about the
the fact that this is an act this is a
full application therefore is
is sort of deliverable and yet i now
hear that the applicant owns more sites
have got planning mission where he
hasn't delivered
uh can you just explain that to me
or give me full of details anyway
again if i can respond sir yes fine
laura
um the comment is is meant more
that as a full application if the
applicant has gone to
sort of the the time expense and input
of putting a full application together
generally we would find that it's a site
that's more likely to come forward
than sort of a speculative outline
application
with just a red line in all matters
reserved and obviously then they'd have
a better chance of actually delivering
it within a reasonable time frame as
well rather than
subsequently coming in with a reserved
matters application and i hope that
clarifies the point
yeah thank you and uh whilst we've got
this picture up of the access onto the
the site
uh it does look incredibly narrow can i
ask because the lamp post is set back
from the road does that mean
that it can be widened there or is that
the actual access what i'm seeing here
michael would you like to comment on
that please or
laura
yeah i'll take it if you like um the
i really didn't want to get into this
again but the the lamp column i believe
is in within the service strips
um but that is that is correct that's
the access stub at the end yeah
right so so who owns the land with the
lamp post then
um the land is owned by the householders
um but there's highway rights over them
i think we've seen this
um people have been on planning
committee a while remember a couple um
we've had like this before so the
service uh so so there's highway rights
over the service strips which are
usually about a meter wide
rochelle thank you can i interrupt chair
my hand up is not working on my computer
all right councillor uh councillor locke
and then councillor wiseman
yeah i mean some of my concerns have
been
um addressed by the um
alterations to condition nine
um because i do have some sympathy with
the parish council about peace meal
development
and also the highways officer on page 15
quotes um this piecemeal approach to
plan is not considered good planning
and it's likely to result in disjointed
development at the wider area
um but as we all know we have to
consider
what is in front of us and i also was
going to mention as
peter christie's mentioned on page 27
that i didn't agree with the plan
officer's comment
just because an application is made in
full
that it will be delivered um my question
with
word and on condition nine um
with the name and or the given of that
number that
um site is that the site with the two
affordable
houses on or is that the other site
laura i think it's the ones with the too
affordable on
but laura you can answer that
yeah just trying to find the right uh
slide if i can um
let's see i think it's
um this one here um yes is the site with
the two affordable
units on it i'm i'm trying to recall
no i apologize it's not the site with
the affordable units on it the
affordable units
are to the north of the sort of
section and they're the two smaller
units shown on the
left hand side oh because i was going to
ask
if that was the case that then the two
affordable that perhaps we could
extend that condition further by saying
the occupation of one affordable and one
open market
but we can't do that then because that's
not the right side
no i mean we've referred to the
application sites and
and the development that was approved
for the five because those are the
three to the south of the access road
and the two immediately to the north
so they would be the ones that would
require the access road in the first
instance
um so so that was the reason that
application for five dwellings had no
affordable
on it right
thank you very much i'll stop there for
a moment
thank you coach a lot counselor wiseman
oh thank you chair
just uh just you know i'm sorry but i'm
going to carry on from
before with a couple of bits um
there's uh i did am i correct in
thinking that
we no longer counted garages spaces as
parking space
they not heard that if i
i can respond chair um
we would normally still consider them um
but we are
aware of the fact they're often used for
storage rather than for parking
provision
um but in this instance we've still got
at least one off street parking space
um for each unit and in most cases
two just the in the report they
mentioned garage spaces as well and i
thought we weren't no longer counting
those because we know that the cars
don't get parked in
garages do that and there's plenty of
room on plot one for a second space but
anyway
um i also i'm concerned about um access
to property four for any delivery vans
and
so forth even refuse trucks they're
gonna have to back down all the way down
that
access road around that 90 degree corner
and then into the
previously appointed development before
they can turn around
and get away that seems quite
unsatisfactory is there any chance that
we can insist that there's a turning
space
where that 90 degree bend is
chaired i don't know whether mike
newcomb is happy to respond on that one
laura could you just point out on the um
on the map that got in front of you
where we're talking about sorry just
just presumably just where the spur is
to the north yeah
exactly yes yes yes i believe it's it's
this
junction here yeah um
i i
wouldn't particularly support that um
like i said it's not unusual for lengths
like that to be reversed on
um yeah i said that that's
this isn't extraordinary by any means
that seems like a bit of a wasted
opportunity really doesn't it
um yeah sorry
sorry can i just say that i mean the
bottom line is do i think if we took
this to appeal
would would we um would we win on that
basis no i do i think we struggle to um
to take that to appeal i think they
would argue that it's built to standard
okay and um broadening
the look the ecology
that piece that seems to me that we're
not increasing
the habitat and so forth that small
there's quite a length of hedge for
going to be removed there
and that short piece of hedge at the
bottom the south side of
um plot two there's no way that that
will compensate
surely
the road is going to be built the hedge
is going to be removed
and the access road is going to be built
along the hedge line yeah
there's a long section of hedge going to
be removed there
there's a new section of hedge going to
be put in at the south side of plot two
i assume that that is to some extent to
uh to
abate the damage that we're doing by
removing that hedgerow
well it could be considered cancer
wiseman yeah
as compensation he also i suppose is to
give the privacy plot to to that garden
of plot two well
are we not really are we not reducing
the amount of habitat
we're supposed to be increasing the
amount of habitat in ecology
which seems appears to me that we're
reducing it
does that not make sense for everyone
yeah
yeah obviously it depends to what extent
isn't it
well we all know that hedgerows are
important to our biodiversity and
allowing animals to traverse from one
habitat to another along the hedge line
and so forth
it doesn't seem very satisfactory to me
there we are anyway i'll wait to hear
what else is said
thanks councillor wiseman councilman
goff
famous chairman i do apologize the wi-fi
cut me off just a moment ago
one question on page 28 on the
recommendation is a contribution
of the 106 of 16 432 pounds towards
additional
education infrastructure at bradweby
primary school
in layman's terms can you explain to me
how this actually going to benefit
the brad beverly primary school
sounds great scene and writing but how
does it actually benefit the school
please
can i respond chair yeah laura
that's sort of the standard wording that
the county council
would put in their response and often it
can lead to additional classroom spaces
um or additional construction of an
extra area for pupils
um i can also let you know that recently
there has been a planning application
for bradworthy primary school for
additional classroom spaces
which has been permitted so i i think
there is
a will there if you like in terms of of
putting forward additional
additional classroom space to
accommodate new new developments
and additional people numbers thank you
thanks laura
you muted councillor mcgoff
yes mr chair i meet you too you said i
could come in again to come back i was
being a good point and
waiting me turn can i come back to that
please yeah of course you can
lovely okay that sounds nice
sounds good how can we guarantee the
money actually goes towards the school
could the highways officer actually
answer that to me
obviously you know he's part of the
department i would put this pre-wording
in
i don't think that that's anything to do
with mike no it's nothing to do with
highways
it's a contribution to the education
authority have asked for
not highways and
as laura said there's a planning
application been approved for an
extension to the school
so obviously the county council i would
assume are going to use that money
towards the
extension of the school and that's what
it's for
good anything else counts in my golf i
think we've lost him again
no he's muted right anybody else want to
cancel lot did you want to come back at
all
no rubble alex
i'll just say then that you know this is
the one of these difficult planning
decisions
and you've got to put on a tilted
balance when you are considering it
um i am with the
improvement on condition number nine
that two houses have built on a previous
application
i find this application easier to
approve so i will move approval subject
to the condition
number nine being autistic thank you
okay
yeah yeah it's um got no hands coming up
on my um
share screen so um can i just go on and
say to you my concern is
um for the children in the area of um
elm lee
because they do play there so i just
wondered what
protection can we give those children
when trafficker
exiting from the new site can there be
give way signs or
children playing is that an appropriate
question to ask of highways please
um yeah i mean primarily i i know this
isn't i'm not gonna win any
friends by saying this comment but the
the public highway is there for the safe
and expedient movement of traffic in the
first instance
roads and highways are dangerous places
we teach our kids that
um and i almost struggle to say that it
is it's not really a planning argument
to to
um put that forward with the guys
assigning the lining everything we do
that has to be put on the public highway
has conformed to the tsrgd which is the
um
the traffic signs and regulations and
directions
manual it's about that thick in this
room insomniac please don't bother
reading it
but um i think looking uh you know from
previous i think we would struggle
to put any kind of signing lining up
that would um
that would be of any benefit here really
um like i said there has to be certain
conditions and
the reason is is to stop the
proliferation of signing in other areas
so in other words if we put children
playing for example
children crossing signs they are
specifically meant to be used
at either nurseries or um
schools or in close proximity of schools
and the reason is to stop them
springing up on every estate throughout
the whole country when you drive on the
states
you should just be careful and like i
said this is a this is a low-speed
environment anyway
um and relative view vehicles
so um the bottom line is i think we
would struggle to um
put any reasonable signing up that would
make a lot of difference
mike just to pick up on what counselor
brown said
yeah i do remember that in many areas of
the country
play streets used to be signposted with
access only so it used to say beware
children
play street access only meaning
only people with business with vehicles
to go onto the site
and i would have thought off north road
onto elizabeth lee close
something like that could be put up a
sign warning that
at least given a bit of advance warning
it could be children playing in the
road along that there's nowhere else for
them to play on that
what will be if this is approved at
quite an and the already
approved site for 10 there it'll be
quite a
big estate reasonably sized state
there's no place space for anybody you
are quite
i certainly have a sympathy for what
you're saying but like i said that the
knock-on effect of this is and the
reason that tsrgd is so
strict is that the you know
the this this is not a unique
arrangement you know we've seen
hundreds it's not if if not more of
these kind of um
developments in the states throughout
the throughout devon and the rest of the
country
and i said there would just be a massive
proliferation if we started a president
for
that which by the way would be against
what tsrgd recommends
all right thanks for that council watson
and then councillor craig
oh thank you chair um yeah
i've listened to it all now if um
if counselor lock is proposing it i will
second it
uh but it's also nice to hear that
somebody has finally asked
does the money actually go to
in this instance to bradworthy school
it's one of the things that um
i think actually our council should look
into
even more and and um find out from
devon county actually where the money
does go to because
always the chief education officer is
really there to take the money
and it would be really for me it would
be really nice to check up on that and
and hopefully i will
peek into on this afternoon and we might
be able to do that but yeah if
um council lock is proposing it i'll
second it
thanks council watson council craigie
thank you chair um i just wanted to
support councillor brown
because i feel that when you look at the
entrance to the estate
it's clear that it is um just
a cul-de-sac the way the road is
constructed
from the blocks rather than tarmac and
the fact there's no pavement at all
it seems quite a narrow road and it
it does seem as if it's inappropriate to
take
large estates of
a small call this act like this um
the road is not designed for children to
get to the side of the road you know to
be on the pavement they've got nowhere
to go
and i think that should be taken in into
consideration
quite seriously that if if a car is
coming from
both directions and there are children
playing on the road or where where are
they supposed to go
to are they supposed to jump into
people's gardens
i i just i love the bungalows and i
i would love to support more bungalows i
really would
but i feel as if it's the access
consideration
because we're building quite a big
estate here and it's clear from the way
the road is placed and they're hoping to
get another development to the east
of this with more bungalows because
otherwise they'd have put all the
conservatories
facing the the tree you know the fields
at the back
we we're sort of setting ourselves up
for for future development
i take the point about the service
vehicles
not being able to get in and out and i
like the development and i would really
like to support it
but i just cannot because of the access
thank you thank you councillor craig
councillor watson yes chair um
well i i understand where where council
brown and councillor craig are coming
from
but let's not forget here there is
already two sites approved
so the traffic will already
if they were if they were built it would
already be going down there
and all we're looking at is is an extra
for bungalows
so you know all this all this argument
about
you know the kids playing etc etc fine i
understand about that i used to play on
the road when i was a kid
um but
i just don't understand how we can
go against this application because
of children playing on the street when
the two the other two sites are there
and approved
to build the guy could build them now if
you wanted
and and and so which would have that
situation anyway
which we could not stop
so how can we try to stop that
just because four bungalows are going
there i i'm sorry
you know i sympathize but i can't agree
that that is a reason that we should
go against these four bungalows thanks
councillor watson
um sean you want to come in there
uh thank you chair if i may um can i
just respond to some of the discussions
that the
members have raised with your permission
chair
um firstly in relation to the education
contribution
uh it is actually a very good uh point
that customer golf raises about
the um the money whether it go to the
school or not
um it is actually the wording is
actually put within the section 106
quite tight so it has to go that way um
and if it's not spent the money's
returned over a period of time
and i do know that the education
authority do get requests
from um applicants agents and the like
uh for evidence confirmation that
money's been spent for that very reason
obviously seeking a refund if it hasn't
been spent
so they do keep an audit trail of it
what i can do if it
if it helps committees i can contact the
education authority in the future
and report back to the next committee in
relation to that
and the process that goes through the
education authority
which may give confidence moving forward
that that is the case
but officers are confident that it will
go to the local school
so that's in relation to the education
contribution in relation to access
i think uh officers have something with
the discussions that members are having
at the moment we've got the safety of it
however i would um
i would signal caution uh given the
highway authority's response about the
reasonableness of
any um reasons for refusal based on
highway safety
given the number of dwellings and that
highway network and the
um county council responds who are the
professionals in their field on that
and clearly we have to um as council
lock says
we have to consider what's in front of
us and what may or may not happen in the
future
um clearly if an application does um
come in in the future
that will be considered on its own
merits we've got the impact on the
highway
but what's in front of councillors at
the moment members at the moment
is the application that they see on
their screen in front of them thank you
chair
thank you sean uh right well i'll have
my little say on it
um laura if you could go back to the
bd01
plan right at the start i think it was
that one now bd01 there i noticed from
the already consented permission on here
has already gone outside that boundary
to the
south is it towards the bowling green on
what's already been approved
so they've already that's correct that
previous application
extended brd01 outside the boundary of
that
and we're talking about yeah that's all
right i just wanted to be clear because
when i saw that uh i thought well
the previous application's already gone
outside that boundary
um industrial extension been mentioned
and
you see the industrial estate there well
i would have thought that
there is there is um
scope for various extensions from there
if necessary in the future
without coming through um
this estate through elizabeth lee close
i certainly wouldn't want
an industrial estate at the end of
elizabeth lee close
i don't think that will be suitable but
there is there is a
access to extend the industrialistic
in the in the other area there if if
needs be
in the future so i'm not worried about
the comments that the parish council
made about
extending the industry of the state the
attenuation bond what i would ask is
it's on the applicant's own land
how would they be responsible for
maintaining that there's nothing in the
uh conditions about maintenance of that
attenuation bomb it may silt up or fill
up
and be so how are we going to monitor
that that is
appropriately managed nor you've got
your hand up
yes chair just to um go back on the
comment about uh
the extension of the brdo one allocation
on page 14 of the agenda outlines the
history of the adjacent sites
the five dwellings which were part of
the outline application in 2017 were the
ones that extended to the south
it was refused by us but approved on
appeal by the planning inspector
and so just to make you aware of that
um with respect to
sorry i'm trying to record your the
other query you have you had apologies
you could just replace your generation
yes there was
um details on the um surface water
drainage plan
um which i will try and pull up i'm not
sure they're overly clear on
on the screen we've got here um
they do put forward details of how
this will be operated and maintained
right on the bottom of the
the surface water drainage plan and that
is detailed
as one of the approved plans within the
recommendation in front of you
that's all right i thought that when
they put that forward that it would be
tied up in some way but i've not read it
anywhere but that's fine that's all
right
um i do agree actually with other
members about the access
i've never liked these small
um access roads onto estates and
elizabeth lee close when it was first
built
is an arrow which is a narrow road and
there are no footballs but it is
common on many estates in in our
district
that these brick pavilion roads are put
in without any footpath
and there's a little grass strip you see
along the side as michael
michael was saying is a service
for the services to run and that is
where people are
if they want to walk off the actual hard
surface walk along there
but um i'm going to support the
application because there's no valid
planning reason for us to refuse it
i'll take the point that um councillor
watson ray is
uh sorry councillor wiseman raised about
the loss of that hedge and we are
supposed to be enhancing
uh these sites where when we can
and through that field which is going to
be a post and rail fence
it would have been nice to have seen a
devon hedge bank along there
and that would have increased the
biodiversity of the site
but we can only do robots before us
and
yeah laura could you come back in then
thank you chair i'm i'm aware that
members i raised some queries about
the um the post and rail fence um
previously and sort of questioned me
about that last week
um i spoken to the applicant and the
agent on that basis and asked the
question as to whether they'd be willing
to put a hedge bank along that boundary
and they have said that they would be
willing to do so
um i have sort of put forward
i've got some sort of rough wording of a
potential condition that we could
include and which would tie that up as
part of a recommendation
something along the lines of
notwithstanding the details on this
landscape plan in front of you now
and the eastern boundary of the site
should be formed with the planted bank
and will ask for the details to be
submitted to and approved by us in
writing in advance
well if council councillor lock and
councillor watson are in agreement i'll
i'll make that
a proposal that we do add that condition
because
it to me we should be enhancing the
biodiversity of the site
we're losing some as councillor wiseman
said and i think
it would be vast improvement to have a
hedge bank along that boundary
agreement thanks i agree thanks
thank you council council watson and
thanks laura for
sounding out the applicant and then
being willing when all said and done
boundary treatment is here to be
considered
so i think it's fair enough that that's
uh right well with that
yeah that's two houses have to be built
on the previously
granted permission before they start
building any of these four yeah
yeah that's fine thank you lauren okay
right well it's been proposed and
seconded to grant nets
with the additional condition will be
put in and laura will circulate that
the hedge bank which we've seen a
plan of is along that eastern boundary
instead of a post and rail fence
sandra if you'd like to go to the vault
please
thank you chair councillor belton
against councillor brown
against councillor christie
thanks councillor craigie
against councillor leather
or councillor locke or
councillor mcgough
okay
ask him again sandra pencilling a golf
well we can see him
counselor off can you hear us
counselor golf
well he's online he's there
okay somebody ringing
sandra shall i try and ring him um
yes please councillor watson councilman
mcgove can you hear us
he did say he had problem earlier on
didn't he but he is showing us being
here if he could hear us it would be
better
context
hmm
okay emma wait wait can you read rick
golf can you hear us
i can't i can't enough it online i guess
i can just
i rose don't do something but i can't i
can't access it i don't know why
we can hear you now councilman mcgrath
we can hear you so i'm just trying to
take the vote
it's been moved to approve this rep this
application
i'm for the application thank you okay
chandra i can't i can't somehow i can't
access the ipad it's just it's shutting
down me coming back up
again oh okay you're all right you're
back with us now councillor mcguff carry
on sandra
thank you chair councillor watson
sandra he's just coming back into the
room okay thank you tom
hello councillor watson sorry
you're a vote i'm for it
thank you cancer the wise men
that's been approved chair five four
and four against okay sandra thank you
we got there in the end thanks everybody
for that
right ring thank you everybody
thanks for that councillor watson
forgetting all the council mcguffie did
come back
all right okay did he come back online
then could he speak yeah he did yeah
yeah all right only on his phone that
wasn't online as that's only on his
phone
yeah yeah well he can anybody hear me
now
yes we can yeah i i do apologize i just
couldn't
i couldn't access the ipad i don't know
what's happened to it but it's back on
there i've
done something to it i'm on it now sorry
okay thank you
thanks mate thank you councilman right
we'll move on then
oh where are we we're at set where
appeal decisions on agenda item eight
now
which is appeal decision summary pages
33
to 40. yes chad can i
point out something on page 36 council a
lot yeah
um that's due with the west the village
square at westwood hall
um page 35
bullet point number nine i was really
pleased to see that that the inspector
considered that
the decision was only made on its merits
not the lack of contact
with the applicant so i was really
pleased to read that so as i wrote
yeah okay yep
right anything else on the people's
decisions
from anybody right we'll move on item
nine on the agenda is costs on appeals
where there aren't any
item 10 on the agenda is delegated
decisions
a gmb council lock
i'm getting ready for number 42 oh
no no
we'll move on then to planning decisions
uh planning decisions which are on page
42 to 54. so i'll go through the pages
42 council council
second one down i'm glad laura's here
but that was nora's decision
um i was quite surprised that this
didn't come to committee really or
i've looked but we've been talking about
education
and contributions and when i looked at
this application
i see that there was absolutely no
response from devon county council
education department
as to whether they wanted the
contribution there were ten
houses i would have thought they would
have replied to that so i just wonder if
laura
do why
laura laura are you still with us can
you catch your mind after that
uh i am counsellor i'm i'll apologize
this is a
report i wrote quite some time ago the
section 106 negotiations were quite
protracted on this one well
it's kind of a lot putting you on the
spot and that's not really really
i'm very i'm very happy to go back
through the uh the file and come back to
her
um individually on that but um i
genuinely don't know
off the top of my head i apologize i
just thought it was unusual because i
always replied
no no certainly i'll have a quick look
through and i'll come back to you
thanks laura thank you right page 43
44 page 45
46 47
48 49
50 51
52 and then on 53 you've got
the refused ones and the not permitted
development
age 54 is the final one
good answer christy yeah can i just
ask about one thing um you've seen that
uh the appeal from alan smith at
westwood hall was turned down
you may recall he had another
application in um
the the cave or the wedding area he does
he's withdrawn that
yeah i called that one in and i only
learned by accident
they've been withdrawn um can there be
some
uh not a rule but some thing in place
where
if a counselor does call something in
and it is later withdrawn they can
actually be told because yeah
you ought to be yeah i thank you yeah
sean you'll take that up and clear it
out uh yes chair thank you council
christie
um yeah we can do that that's uh that's
appropriate to do so
lovely okay thank you
right well there's nothing else to
discuss nobody else has got the hands up
so i'll declare the meeting closed at
10 47 is it 10 47.
thank you okay can we go
are we offline now